What am I supposed to just let somebody call me a stalker? Somebody
called me a stalker and now I have to I have to correct that.
I have to go live right now and correct it. They call me a stalker
and I'm not a stalker. Nobody deserves this time >> to
be compared to or treated like destiny. Nobody deserves that.
No human being deserves that, dude. You can you chill? Can you
chill? Can you chill? Can you chill? Can you chill?
I think I said we'd do a little snarking after this. We we got
a Hassan segment for just a little little bit of Stark. Okay,
we did say that we would do it for for a treat. And >> apparently
this is this is how some this is how libs need to think about
Grant Platiner that says this account. It's sex pesty. It's epony
and it's platiner and a Republican on the ballot. As long as
there is breath in my body, hand can grip a pen and can mark
a ballot. I'm voting for the blue guy. Platner would get the
vote. But do not expect me to come out here and simp for him
or actively defend him when he is in bed. >> Oh no. What
will we do?
What will what will Mayers do, guys? Epstein, the guy who uh
is currently in a court case for distributing
uh revenge in exchange for child abuse material.
Uh is is that
>> Wait, that is actually an accurate recollection. It's
a little bit of malicious accuracy.
Leaves out some facts that probably would be required to come
to an unbiased opinion, but it is in fact quite accurate. >> He's
written an manifesto and his right to be able to say the has
decided that he's not going to defend Graham Platner. Okay. Well,
I'm glad that he at least says he's going to vote blue no matter
who. At least he's got that principle down. That's good. With
all of the worsting people on the planet with these tanky commie
loser, for all I know, this guy could be Federman 2.0. No,
>> Why does he hate John Federman?
Isn't John Federman literally everything that he likes? John
Federman and and Epstein.
>> John Federman is just Destiny stacked on top of Destiny.
Okay, that's all John Federman is. Little more incoherent, but
really Destiny's catching up to him. So,
>> Have the same level of admiration and support for the
nation state of Israel. Yeah. John Federman became aligned
with
As a matter of fact, I'm willing to bet there's probably instances
initially
uh when John Ferman was making that pro-Israel pivot where Epstein
probably defended him.
I'm sure there's clips of it out there cuz why wouldn't he? He
was sucking Israel super hard just like Federman >> Even
Federman is preferable to a Republican, but I don't expect anybody
to be happy about it. It's so funny because you talk to these
stupid lefty commie, okay, and you're like, "Did you guys ever
support Kamla?" And they're like, "Yeah, go back and look." And
every single video is like, "Well, Trump is bad. Trump is bad.
Trump is bad. Trump is bad. Trump is bad. Trump is bad." Would
the Democrat be better? Maybe. Hassan said no.
>> That's quite literally the tactic, by the way. That
that's like all everybody is asking for. That's been the strategy
explicitly the whole time. That's what Josiah does.
By the way, none of this is like Destiny's idea. This is all
just him lifting stuff from Josiah, who's a far more intelligent
and informed political operator. But that's all that's all Destiny
bases most of his opinions that aren't totally on. He just takes
them from Josiah. Which is why I've recommended Hutch do it directly
cuz Hutch kind of gets in trouble trying to look to Destiny for
stuff when Destiny's riffing. All Hutch needs to do is just go
watch Josiah's videos like Destiny does multiple times. Yeah,
the messaging was mixed at best. But now all of the commies seem
to understand. Hold on. It's not enough to just say that I guess
you'd support Plato. You need to be excited about it. You got
to be enthusiast. Like none of this stuff >> I don't really
care about that at all. There this is a
this is a complete straw man. I don't give a if he doesn't I
mean if he comes out against
Grant Platner then that's a violation of any principles that
he may have tried to maintain. But outside of that I don't give
a what is this? He literally didn't know who Susan Collins was.
>> None of you would support um I don't Is Susan Collins
actually that bad? I don't even know. But everybody in my sub
hates >> She's a Republican, but like she does >> Never
mind. Don't care. Don't care. I didn't even know that. Never
mind. I I didn't know she's a Republican. >> This guy's
a political commentator and he doesn't know who the Susan Collins
is. Susan, >> I'm glad I put Hassan back onto this. You
know, I've been talking to Hassan a lot. I've been explaining
that like actually [clears throat] focusing on Destiny's drama
just gets away from the most easy thing to criticize him about
right criticize him about right now. And this is political takes.
He doesn't spend any time doing anything to get like nothing
with politics. All of his political takes, they're from like
two years ago when he actually cared or tried. He's got nothing.
He He is not tracking the moment. He's got no pulse, right? Does
not have the pulse at all. He's like a total politically right
now. That's where he's most vulnerable in terms of being accused
of being some kind of pervert.
Any degenerate of any kind. Destiny has more experience than
you or I will ever have, right? He can defend himself along those
lines forever. He is maybe the most accused of these things on
the entirety of the streamer internet like on on the internet
entirely with regards to streamers. Okay, it's him standing alone
at at the mountaintop attacking him there. Okay, but yeah, you
switch over to politics, man. Oh boy, things get a lot easier.
>> I'm concerned, Collins. Susan, I'm concerned Collins.
Susan, I'm the most moderate uh Trump critic. Collins.
How the do you not even know the most basic [__]
That's insane. He just openly is like, I don't know who the Susan
Collins is. That's Am I crazy? I feel like Susan Collins is like
the fake Joe Mansion of the Republicans. She's famous for that
reason. She's famous for constantly being like, "Oh, I'm concerned.
I'm concerned about what Trump is doing." And then going along
with Trump's agenda 98%
of the way. She's not like some random person. You know what
I This is not like knowing about Angus King, okay? Susan Collins
is a is a a known entity. Veteran is the wrong type of centers
for these guys because he doesn't play ball. Someone like Jared
Golden is a right play right of the party, too, but plays ball
in the big bills for the most part. Oh, they're party men at
the end of the day. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, Jared Golden
is a is a great example. You're right. His Reddit was glazing
Federman whenever he shows his support for Israel.
Oh. Oh, no. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. Not the
receipts.
Oh god.
This is just Apparently this is the new thing in Vogue. Do I
just need imager albums? Guys, can you get me imager albums of
Destiny subreddit right now? Stats. I need Destiny subreddit
images now. I need Destiny Discord images now.
>> Based Federman's a treasure.
Christ Federman is the hero America needs. That's what I mean.
Like these guys have no principles. They just like became pro-Israel
because he's pro Israel. Also, one of the funniest things that
people claim
about Graham Platner is that and it it immediately shows that
your analysis is exclusive to the internet. Okay, I'm not going
to play this video yet, but I saw I think it was uh Hosbbor Points
that was also saying like, "Oh, the internet made Grand Plat
the left is the reason why Grand P." >> So, I responded
to Contra Points on this tweet and just said like, "Isn't his
proof, isn't his ability to like woo these people in a mostly
rural state, isn't it like entirely based on him actually identifying
with working-class people? Like, they do identify with him."
Like she was arguing, yeah, it's all white leftists, like affluent
white leftists who like him. It's like, no.
What do you not understand that like
most of this state has seen him? Most of this state like knows
who he is and
it it just makes no sense. It's a rural state. It's like a massively
rural
How in the world could you be like this working class illusion
or something that's made by white affluent leftists if you have
to go to all these rural communities and talk to people directly?
It just doesn't work. You have to be somebody who does. And people
will say he's not a working-class guy. And I agree he doesn't
come from like a working-class background. But unfortunately
for everybody who wants to make that claim, you'll have to explain
to me how somebody who's a Marine, who's a grunt for half of
their like the first what, eight years of their adult life, five,
five years, however long their first term was, first um deployment.
How does a guy go from being like a grunt in the military to
not being workingass? Like that is a working class job. You're
rubbing elbows with all working class people. It turns out working
class isn't really necessarily all in the money.
It's actually significantly in like how you act, who you interact
with, how you treat people on a day-to-day basis, right? That's
how people think of working class. If you found out one of your
buddies who like doesn't treat you like a piece of [__]
or anything had a little more money than you expected, it wouldn't
really bother you that much,
right? I don't think so. You're kind of becoming a shoe on head
style Twitter poison lefttoid hitting contrar contrarian.
Yes, I think so. Yes, >> platiner is a thing, >> which
is too bad because I don't think she has to. I unfortunately
she's gotten on the wrong side of the Hassan fans and
I I don't know what to do about that cuz she's clearly fighting
with people on Twitter all the time and
he blames Hassan for it. I don't know what else to say. None
of you guys know anything about elections if you are making such
an unbelievably stupid assessment. Okay, your brain has been
poisoned by what you see on Twitter. Your brain has been poisoned
by what you see on Reddit. Your brain has been poisoned by the
communities that you spend a good deal of time in where they
constantly talk about these idiotic narratives. That's why it's
also funny because when he was like, "Oh, it's these [__]
commie tanky [__] that like support Graham
The people that this sex pass would consider commie tanky
actually hate Graham Platner. Okay, that's number one. Number
two, Graham Platner's base of support is not the youth vote.
Okay? Graham Platner's
you you saw in who he was speaking to, right? He's talking about
people who have worked for a long time. He's talking to people
who look as haggarded as he does. Okay? That's who he's talking
to when he's going out and doing his rhetoric. It's for people
who have worked hard their whole lives. They're 40, 50 now, and
they got nothing squirreled away for retirement. They're staring
down the barrel of a gun and they look they think they're like
the people he's talking to a lot of the time, right? Maybe 35
to 55 or something. That's who I think he's talking to most of
the time. Platinum. >> Biggest supporters are not the young
voters of Maine. I'm sure there are plenty of young voters in
Maine that will vote for him, but you're out of your mind. Maine,
the average voter age in Maine is, I believe, 48 years old.
Okay? It's all old white people. These are ride-or- die Democrats
and independents that are sick and tired of Donald Trump the
money. Okay? And they're also very frustrated with the Democratic
parties centrism.
The olds, the whites, the old whites are frustrated. And I've
been saying this for months.
Actually, not even for months. I've been saying this for the
last two years. As a matter of fact, if you recall, I always
repeat to all of you. I'm like, I go around the country. I go
to these protests. I go to the no kings rallies. What do I see?
I see old white people. Old white people that are saying Bernie
was right. And we were wrong for saying Bernie was wrong. Yeah.
Nothing has changed in the last year. Old liberal voters just
want fighters because they're too pissed at Trump. And Platner
is a fighter who calls them fascists. People who characterize
him as left or DSA are fundamentally misunderstanding his appeal.
Absolutely. Let's look at Graham Platner's commie tanky base
now.
Yeah, that is that is the walker of a Hassanabi head right there.
You know, Hassan's average average age of his viewership is like
I think like 55 to 70. That's why he started wearing the suits,
right, for the grandmas.
>> Does this look like a DSA meeting? Maybe DSA pre206
certainly, but there wouldn't be this many people in one room
for the DSA before 2016 anyway. But does this look like a Democratic
Socialism America meeting? Do you think this is the campus caucus?
These are people who were around when Carl Marx was around. The
are you talking about the DSA tankies? You only arrive at this
conclusion if your brain is rotted from the you see on the internet.
Stop.
It's not even rotted. It's actually even worse than that. It
is like a totally
It's like a totally jaded
calculated play to build Hassan up as a villain and be able to
keep your audience around because of that. Right.
That's unironically what it is is it's just a calculated play.
It's a totally
oh it's like a totally jaded there's another word I'm looking
for but it's a totally
oh it's it's just disingenuous play.
Destiny doesn't think that Graham Platner is appealing to communists.
He just knows that he appeals to Hassan and he knows he's got
a whole thing built cynical. Cynical is what I was looking for.
Yes. It's a totally cynical strategy to take advantage of that.
He knows he's got for his audience built up. They they've been
they've had Hassan built up as this enemy as this like villain
who's going to overthrow democracy and he's just retailering
and retooling so he can keep following Hassan.
That's what it is. That's the analysis from their side. I'm not
even joking. That's like all of it. It's very It's just like
It's just weird
because Yeah. Like, and it's why they're missing out on why the
populist movement is like working right now. It's why they're
missing out on how bad the economy has been, right? I I'm almost
positive I'd still hear Destiny go on his same rant about how
the economy is not that bad and you just need to stop ordering
Door Dash. I feel like he's always one second away from going
on that rant again. I feel like he's always on the precipice
of just being like, "No, it's not that bad. had actually more
zoomers that ever own houses. It's like, okay, I don't I don't
know what to tell you, man. Believing these [__]
okay? They are always going to lead you astray. This is pure
personal vendetta masquerading
as real political analysis. And oh, never mind. He he identified
it, too. Okay, never mind. Back it up. Back it up here. By the
way, I like Grand Platner for way different reasons than any
of the leftists around me. Like like I talked to people who are
actual leftists. Like I talked to Straight about Grant Platner
maybe like a week or two ago. Like we have none of the same re
like well I don't even know if she likes Grant Platner at all
actually. But I like Grant Platner
in spite of some of his flaws. Not because of his flaws obviously,
right?
But
I
I have no re It's not because he's a communist. It's because
he's speaking truth to like some underlying realities that need
to be addressed before like there's an actual revolution.
That's why I like him. I don't think that really maps on to a
lot of the reasons other people like him. And there are so many
idiots out there who believe it. They go along with it because
it's much easier to keep up with drama. It's much easier to present
people as villains on the internet and then just focus on the
dumb nonsensical drama. Oh, Hassan has done this again. Hassan
has done that again. I hate Hassan. So, I believe Hassan now
they're telling me Hassan is actually promoting Graham Platner
and he loves Graham Platner and he chose he personally hand selected
Graham Platner and and therefore I hate him too. He's a bad guy.
Where did you arrive at this conclusion? Yeah, I feel like this
whole Platiner situation could have been avoided if a bunch of
upper middle class leftists hadn't seen the most obvious red
flags imaginable and thought that's just a rough salty Ohio Waffle
House type working-class people are like. I blame the New York
Times. They taught people to see stuff like for example a third
WS pan division tomov and think now there's a man with economic
anxiety. What a stupid assessment. Incredibly stupid assessment.
Yes.
Like he literally by the way
he's
that was unironically like un it's unambiguously like a scandal
for him and a problem for him.
And he was he was already starting his campaign. He was already
somebody people liked before that came out. It's not like people
like him because of that. That's never been the case. Whatever.
More um more totally cynical engagement from Natalie. Unlucky.
It was main Democrats that looked at Grant Platner and was like
and were like, "Yeah, this guy speaks to the problems that I'm
experiencing. This guy speaks to the problems that my younger
uh the the you know, my children and my grandchildren are experiencing
because they're old as for the most part." So I I find it so
strange but also very
What is this? I hold a mirror up and none of you What is this?
Lauo.
The world is so much better when Algo stop feeding politics slop
to everyone so these unserious people can go back to watching
Joe Rogan all day. I like that he calls me unserious. I'll hold
a mirror up to you all and none of you like what you see. I have
no problem with the amount of research I put into debating any
of this position. People like Hassan spend zero time doing any
research. Why are you defending yourself in the claim that you
limit your influence by focusing too much on streamer drama by
saying that Hassan does less research than you? I know he does
less research than you, but it has nothing to do with the claim
I made. Okay, this never mind. I [laughter]
to me >> take back everything I said about this guy. I
do less research than Destiny, dude. I swear to God for like
there is definitely there is definitely a a particular brand
of autism that is so
appealing to every poster on the internet where they go no he
has
he's doing he's reading Wikipedia articles to
uh to to develop talking points that he can have like good solid
gotchas on the internet on and that's it that's the extent of
his research his most of his stream is just re-watching videos
of mine which includes probably this >> I will say there's
something I I don't think Hassan can do like a good critique
of Destiny and the way he researches for debates and stuff but
Destiny is broadly
like for a very long period of time Destiny basically just wanted
to be unbeatable in arguments right so he'd set up a framework
in which he would be unbeatable in arguments that's like how
he made himself look good on the internet where he got into trouble
is where he started taking sides on things and then he had to
start bending facts and I think that happened with Israel a little
bit because he had a natural enemy in Hassan and he ended up
taking, you know, moving. You could say he was intellectually
curious. I really don't believe he was on the Israel stuff. Okay.
But he faints intellectual curiosity. He gets pushed over in
the Israel stuff. He ends up kind of making an ass out of himself.
But where it got really bad is once he start had to start talking
about his his
consent violations, right? That's where it got really bad. And
he can't even remotely attach to reality there cuz reality he's
just totally destroyed in reality, right? And so he just has
to start
And so it's never really been about him doing research or trying
to talk about stuff from a point of view trying to express or
get to like the truth or accomplish a goal for good. He just
wanted to be like an unbeatable debater. And and that sounds
Vosch said this once. Vos is way better at explaining this than
I am, I guess. But Vos said this once and it sounds if you hear
it a certain way, it's like, oh, he just wants to be the most
right. Well, isn't that what we all want? But it's not that's
not really what it is, right? It's like just not really having
an
There's just there's not really an ethos there. You are looking
for the the snappiest points you can make in in retort to people.
You are looking for basically like rhetoric trees that you can
defend that are almost impossible to fight against. It's not
really the same as having any kind of open discussion. There
was a period where Destiny also liked open discussion.
I I think I came around that period where it was a lot more open,
a lot less like motivated against anybody.
And that was like an illusion that was like an aberration. Didn't
exist for very long. So anyway, keep watching >> this one
because I just brought him up. So I'm sure he'll he'll take uh
you know tremendous amounts of pleasure off of that. I swear
to God these things these guys genuinely think he's like
uh
a god at debating. If he's doing so much research, why is he
always wrong?
How much research did he deploy with his I guess his political
instincts are really bad then? Because how much research was
he deploying when he said Joe Biden shouldn't drop out? As a
matter of fact, he debated that position on Jubilee literally.
And and by the time the video came out, Joe Biden had dropped
out.
How much research did you deploy when deciding to to take the
opposite stance of mine on the Israel issue and spent two and
a half years, three years defending Israel's genocide with increasingly
more unhinged takes where he got ritualistically humiliated by
Norm Finkelstein because Normicklestein actually knows the he's
talking about? How much research is he deploying when he goes,
"I don't know who Susan Collins is." while talking about Graham
Platner. >> That one's bad. That one's really bad. That's
the other issue he has that I think got cured a lot when he got
a lot of emails from people with different positions, but he
will absolutely like he'll research something to figure out how
to reinforce what he already thinks and it won't take into account
a lot of the like opposing opinions that that gets cured for
him when he gets enough like emails of people calling in and
people who are intelligent and represent a different view in
his community, right? Unfortunately, with all of the allegations
with the whole Pixie case, he sort of loses that ability, right?
a lot fewer people want to interact directly. And so that's what
really robbed him of what appeared to be his his I I guess his
research capability or his ability to form like an opinion most
people would agree with is the Pixie case happened. People were
kind of like, "Ew, gross." And he lost a lot of his network,
a lot of the people who would tell him what to think on things.
Well, it's all downstream of him losing that network of people
who would tell him what to say.
That's that's really what him over the most. Yeah. because I'm
forced to respond to drama claims when other people are making
them. If it's not constantly laundering kiwi farms and snarker
what is a snarker opinion? What is this? What are what is this
talking about me to his audience and then if they carry those
opinions other parts of the internet I have to respond and deal
with them. The entire online political space has been destroyed
by low information ideolog.
It's unironically
it's unironically ade
what am I supposed to just let somebody call me a stalker? Somebody
call me a stalker and now I have to I have to correct that. I
have to go live right now and correct it. They call me a stalker
and I'm not a
Dude, you can you chill? Can you chill? Can you chill? Can you
chill? Can you chill? By the way, Adavar had OCD. She had a like
a pathology that led to that happening. I have no judgment of
her for that, okay? I don't. That could happen to anybody. It
It does feel bad to have people lie about you on the internet.
You just have to engage heavily with the reality of the matter,
which is you can't really do a lot about it a lot of the time.
You can only cut through the noise like that by providing like
a signal in some way by by providing something that that is positive
and is your message is not the thing that that they're saying,
right? That's the only way you can cut through stuff like that.
It sucks to have people lie about you, but realistically, when
there's just no evidence of what they're saying, you're kind
of going to be fine.
>> Logically motivated politic streamers who waste everyone's
time.
The entire political space has been destroyed by low information,
ideologically motivated political politics streamers who waste
everyone's time by trashing the place with drama slops since
they can't contend on factual grounds.
What is this? It I think this is a legitimate tactic, by the
way. Like, not legitimate. It's an illegitimate tactic, but I
do think it's a deliberate effort, a deliberate tactic to just
take the things we're accusing Destiny of and to mirror them.
I think it's a deliberate tactic at this point
where you see a lot of the deliberate like mirroring of the speech,
a lot of the deliberate
mirroring of
phrase like phrasing I guess phrasing and speech the same thing
but a lot of just mirroring like intentional mirroring. We're
all the same. We're all the same. We're all the same.
That's kind of another reason it's nice to focus on the politics
stuff because I can just watch that interview with Scott P and
I can show that we're not the same, right? That's all I got to
do. I can show that we're not the same.
We're not the same at all. I can go give my own take on this.
Go ahead. You go ahead. Give your own take on it. Just like you
did with that Kev Ken Martin interview. You embarrassed yourself.
You mean destiny jacketing? It is destiny jacketing. It is very
gross. It's a disgusting practice to be honest with you. Nobody
deserves >> this time >> to be compared to or treated
like destiny. Nobody deserves that. No human being deserves that.
those opinions. Other parts of the internet, I have to respond
and deal with them. The entire online political space has been
destroyed by low information, ideologically motivated politic
streamers who waste everyone's time. Maybe this is just the swamp
you swim in and there's no getting out. Seems unlikely to me.
There are lots of YouTube political commentators who are involved
in essentially zero personal drama. But supposing it for argument's
sake, but if so, then I'm still right that it puts a ceiling
on your political influence.
Yeah, this guy uh I I like this guy's opinions. I thought he
was intelligent, but he genuinely thinks that, you know, Destiny's
a intellectual
>> Hold on. I hope Assan realizes
Hassan should understand that the reason people think Destiny's
smart is for some reason and you should be able to deconstruct
that or understand it yourself. If you just think it's like he
he like minds people with debate tactics. I I think if you can't
get it like Destiny does spend time there's no better way to
explain why Destiny was more respected intellectually than Hassan
than to go watch that Casey Tron clip. And trust me this is my
weakness too. I have the same weakness as right where I I'm too
wordy. I don't spend any time sharpening the rhetoric getting
it down to phrases getting it down to like catchier bits. Destiny
does do that. Destiny will take a concept and he will whittle
it down until it's very efficient, right? He'd say it in two
sentences.
And so when Casey Tron says, "Well, why didn't we just get Destiny
in here before to explain this to us?" Instead of having Hassan
like yap for however long,
that to me
is
why Destiny was like looked at this way. It has a lot to do with
it, right?
And I
don't like this guy. Obviously, you're defining demagoguery right
now. No, I'm not. I'm I'm basically saying he comes up with like
punchy ways of phrasing things such that they cut through, such
that they are rememberable. Rememberable.
Memorable. Memorable. Not rememberable, but memorable. Yeah.
But I'm I'm saying that there's stuff Assan could do to be taken
more seriously in that way. And I think sharpening sharpening
rhetoric so that you can deliver it and hitting the same points
over and over again. I feel like Hassan and I have the same issue.
So I'm like totally sympathetic that I will have a way I can
explain something but it's usually roundabout and I know I get
the point across to anybody watching but it takes like 5 minutes
and there are other people who could do it in like 30 seconds
and those people will always have like a better clip. They'll
always be better at explaining it. Right.
>> He's not even good at debating anymore. very recent
got smoked in a debate by a two 100 view slob tubers. Yeah.
Let's go.
What is this? Things destiny deeply things destiny believed in
a week's following. [laughter] October 7th. Palestine has an
air force. Palestinians have advanced film production industry
which used to fabricate footage of atrocities. Palestinian is
not a real ethnicity and are secretly Jordanian. Hamas makes
cookie rockets and doesn't really believe the in the pal conspiracy
theories. I knew he was up some stupid [__] but it's
worse than I expected. Yes, this is the clip from later on in
his talking about the subject when he is trying to hedge on the
claim that he thinks the pywood label makes uh palwood label
makes the seem less >> At one point they tried CPR, but
there is no bringing him back his husband and father. He has
another innocent Palestinian civilian killed while posing no
threat whatsoever. [sighs and gasps] >> Somebody died.
How is this paliwood? Because the goal is to capture like this
because Western media eats the up. This guy's wife and a whole
medical team are what I guess minutes or two walk off camera
and this guy's going to walk towards where they know the idea
is where he's been told to evacuate. They know they're going
to get fired at. They're murders because she right. This is what
they're doing is they walk forward hoping to get shot at and
then they're going to come back. They're going to get video footage.
They bring his wife forward. She cries just cuz they actually
die. >> They're going to get fired at. They're
>> They're martyrs.
>> They're shahed, right? This is what
>> Shahed doing is they walk forward hoping to get shot
at and then they're going to come back. They're going to get
video footage. They bring his wife forward. She cries. I just
because it's pal doesn't mean somebody actually die. Okay, these
guys are willing to blow themselves up. Of course, they're willing
to die on camera. So, he comes forward, he gets shot, they bring
him back, he dies. That's unfortunate. They probably don't want
to die. They just want to get shot or shot at. Um, bring him
back. Wife comes forward to cry. Hospital people take him away.
And then they've got their footage. They send it to Western media.
And then they played it a million times to show Israel as this
heartless evil coldhearted monster that just kills uh civilians
indiscriminately. This is like they literally say they're going
into a combat zone. This is what people mean when they say >> how
is this any different than Ben Shapiro trying to intellectualize
his unbelievably putrid worldview. By the way, it's the exact
same thing. As a matter of fact, they are in complete alignment
on this issue. >> The the woman seemed really really really
upset in this clip if I remember correctly, right? She seemed
like totally distraught that her husband was >> Okay, these
guys are willing to blow themselves up. Of course, they're willing
to die on camera. So, he comes forward, he gets shot, they bring
him back, he dies. That's unfortunate. They probably don't want
to die. They just want to get shot or shot at. Um, bring him
back. Wife comes forward to cry. Hospital people take him away.
And then they've got their footage. They send it to Western media.
And then they played it a million times to show Israel as this
heartless, evil, cold hearted monster that just kills uh civilians
indiscriminately. This is like they literally say they're going
into a combat zone. This is what people mean when they say power.
How is this any different than Ben Shapiro trying to intellectualize
his unbelievably putrid worldview? By the way, it's the exact
same thing. As a matter of fact, they are in complete alignment
on this issue. But once again, once again, he delivers this information
with confidence
in a way that is like very palatable to not knowledgeable people.
If you are in any way, shape, or form, >> I will say
that this was before the Rose stuff came out, before you knew
that this guy got and I will say that just by virtue of not having
the goatee, even though I know this guy is off to
I still think he looks and seems less like a now that he has
a full beard again rather than the goatee. The goatee was like
such a massive mistake. It's really hard to overstate just how
bad. Could you imagine if you had a goatee now just how bad it
would be? It would be insane. >> Knowledgeable or empathetic
as a person. And you have seen the the amount of violence that
Israel subjected the Palestinians to over the many years that
Israel is, you know, operated as a part state. You obviously
hear something like this and you go, "Oh my god, this is an unbelievably
racist narrative. How the [__] did this guy learn
about Hosbbor? He's just some like American Cuban dude. Why the
does he Why is he so goddamn tapped in?" like he's hen mazic
or something, right? But if you're not knowledgeable, if your
first interaction with the issue of Israel happens to be this
guy whose videos you've seen on the internet where he's dunking
on some of the stupidest mouth breathers you've ever seen, and
you're like, "This guy's a beacon of intellect. He's a giant
in his own right."
He has the capacity to convince you that his worldview is actually
impenetrable. It's it's unshakable. It's the correct position
and it's actually the most wellressearch wellressearched position
you can arrive at. That's why he consistently will undermine
my positions to be like, "Oh, he's unserious." Between me and
him, I wonder who's the less serious one. the guy who watches
my stream for the most part or the guy who's out there like interviewing
candidates, going to political rallies,
and for the most part covering the news with I feel a little
bad for Han cuz he's doing all of these things and he's still
like quite disturbed by people who haven't gotten the memo about
like him doing all this good stuff.
Like I ah I feel bad for him in that like he clearly did some
of this stuff. Maybe not with the primary goal of being recognized
for it, but certainly like a secondary goal of now people won't
say I'm like this fake champagne socialist who never lives his
values in the world and then people just keep saying it. It's
like oh well that's they just said it because they they believed
it. They just would have said it anyway. Do you know what I mean?
And you can just tell he wanted that to sort of disappear and
it's not disappearing and it sucks.
because like he is actually doing real world like he's actually
going out and doing stuff now even you could argue over how effective
it is and I wouldn't argue it's ineffective but some people would
regardless he's going out and doing stuff and you can tell he
wanted that reputation to go away and it just keeps kind of dogging
him I I feel genuinely like slightly bad for him you know I'm
sure I'm sure all I have to do is think okay this guy does get
all those he has all those women obsessed with him he's got millions
of dollars he lives in like one of the nicest neighborhoods in
the world you know Maybe, maybe he'll be okay. Maybe he'll be
all right. I think he'll be okay. I think he he'll make it. >> Very
rare exception. He is the dumb guys
thinker.
He makes dumb guys feel confident. He makes dumb guys feel like
he's a brilliant person and if they just like try to do a bad
job at repeating what he's saying that they'll also come across
as brilliant.